You know,
when you go to Russia,
you take that attitude like let's
just see what the experience,
so you have your own
experience of what Russia's,
I'm going to have my own expansion.
I let it be what anyone else's.
And also I had been to Russia before I
went in [inaudible] 95 I used to work for
a company that made documentaries,
these guys,
and I ended up going along
to help him out with,
it was the first time I'd ever left. The
U S is a big, uh, had a big effect on me.
So I, um, do you know how to speak
it? No, no, no, no. I mean, I can't,
I can do my, I can do my instructions
it, and I know some words. I mean,
I took some time to learn how to use
the alphabet so I can get around,
you know what I mean? It's
crazy. Yeah. And so, you know,
it's like Celtic ancient cyrillic or
what it's called. Is that what it is?
It's a guy named surreal. So I
thought, well, how the cyrillic yet,
but it's actually named after a guy who
made it. That's the, the Russian stuff.
What does that Celtic stuff that you
know, that you know the, Oh yeah, those,
those rooms. The little
rooms or something? Yeah.
It looks like, yeah. Yeah.
The letters in Russia. Like why is it
that, why would they do it backwards?
Like it's the same letter that
we have, but it's backwards.
Right? Right. Yeah. Yeah.
That's a, yeah. You're talking
about, is that what it is?
He has the one that looks like a backwards
are. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. That's,
that's what they, that's the,
yeah. What does that stand
for over there? Just means,
yeah. Yeah. And as you use it,
like I told you that, that chaos.
So that's how you say I, you said, yeah,
look at their fucking language
and look what's up with that age.
What's up with that? Ups Ages
and ages. The end. Why? But
that's how you use it in.
Oh my God. So like when you,
so once you get used to read,
so you always see pectoral
pile everywhere you go. Right.
What's that Lebanese restaurant?
What's the upside down? Little Age.
So it looks like a candle holder.
Yeah. Right there. What's that? Yeah,
that's an upside down h uh huh.
What happened there?
So we took that h and dumped it on its
head but, but it looks like h doesn't it?
Like if you flipped it upside down,
it's WIC. The look at the e below that.
Like what the fuck is that thing? And so
that's a yacht that that backwards are.
Yeah.
So you would say you would use it like Ja
and say that word when you use it like,
and like just how we use I,
oh, I and we usually like I,
and then we might use it in another
reason too. Yeah. Wow. Yeah.
Thorough.
I mean it is kind of amazing how different
the way we write is to the way Asian
folks do. That's right. That
real freak out. That's, and I,
I think you just have to learn
it, right. Each one of them,
you have to learn each and every
one of those there. Demi, it seems,
it looks like it's pretty hard to learn.
Well it looks,
especially if it's not
completely ingrained in your
memory as a child because I
ended up late in life.
I know there's some people who speak
mandarin but they can't write it. Yeah,
that's right. And you didn't write
it. Yeah. Fuck man. It's alien.
Alien.
I mean the fact that whole different side
of the world writes that way and these
little characters. So I do have
some help when I go over there.
I'm going to tell you something.
I got married a few years ago and my
wife is Russian. Ah, there you go. Yeah,
and she speaks Chinese. So when I got
to China reads and writes Chinese.
So when we go to these
countries and rights, yes. It's
easier to learn. Yeah. Wow.
An English or no English. Yeah.
You get along. We get along because
some people are good with
languages. Man, that's a grubber.
Spanish is better than mine are
already just got here to have Russian,
which has its own use of the
alphabet and then Chinese,
which is another whole deal.
N English just does she have room
in our head for anything else?
I know hard drive would be full. Yeah.
That's this is those three languages.
Like fuck three hard languages.
Right. Probably the hardest.
I heard the rushes hard and English.
Well I'm not going to say hurt.
I tried to allow me to try and learn it.
It's hard.
There's so many ways to say
something cause they conjugate a lot.
I think they a lot more than Spanish real.
And that's what I have problems with.
You know,
we all get Spanish words,
we live in La but conjugating
verbs that you know,
but she can do it easy cause she's like
aw cause they conjugate so much more.
Yeah. It's, that's,
this might be the three hardest language
to learn outside of maybe the other one.
Other Asian languages like Japanese
is probably pretty difficult.
I heard the Vietnamese is
tough. Yeah. And then you know,
you've got those languages that you
look at, you know. Wow, that's great.
And then you see like ancient Hebrew,
you look at Hebrew language like the
way they write. Like what the fuck?
I don't know. I bet Arabic stuff
Arabics gotta be tough. I mean,
how many languages are there?
If you had to guess. Yeah,
a hundred days doesn't dialects and
depending on like where you are.
Even in Mexico there's different, yeah,
speak the same Spanish down there.
Even in Spanish he had like you
can under like, cause you know,
I took a couple of Spanish classes. Right.
But I can understand people from, from,
you know, uh, Spain easier for
some reason I grew up right here.
It's harder for me to understand
that the way they speak Spanish,
my friend lives in, um, my friend Adam
Green tree, he lives in Australia and uh,
he has a lot of experience with like the
indigenous people that live there cause
he uh,
works in a mining company and they,
they deal with a lot of
the aborigines and um,
they have the groups of
people they call the mobs.
That's what they call themselves instead
of like a village or clan or the coals
off a mob. That's what,
that's what aborigines shoes.
And they have different
languages for different moms.
So like there might be hundreds of mobs
in this area and they all have different
languages. So you drive. I go how
close? He was like a few miles.
I go a few miles,
you know he'd say kilometers,
it might make 2000 kilometers like so you
go to a hundred kilometers and you got
a totally different language.
Oh that's all the different languages.
Is that map of all the things
that maybe they're similar, right.
Areas of the moms?
I don't believe so.
I think they don't know what the fuck
each other is saying. Right, right.
That's why we can't understand
Australians. Right. Cause
if you look at that,
that's crazy. Yeah. Like I
don't know who's documenting
all this stuff and what a,
whether or not they've saved these
languages and they, they have it.
Cause it's very likely that like
little ones of them will just go,
you know, if this people assimilate
other populations or, or move out,
like you might lose these languages.
Yeah.
There's something I like
about going to Russia to,
cause there's so many different cultures
and so many people and I liked it.
I like people like I get that, I get
the like a, I get to go to Graziani.
It'd been got to, I've been to Dagestan
to Graziani is in Chechnya. Yeah.
What's that like? It's really,
it was a really cool place.
I went to a show you some pictures, went
to uh, uh, went and looked around. What,
because it's,
for me what's really cool about it
is the energy that people have about
developing over there right now. Because
the place, there was a war there,
you know about that, right? Yeah.
There was a war and a right now and
they're really building up and they're
really excited about it.
So I think it's just, uh,
it's cool to go and see
people who are really, uh,
see I kind of a group of mentality
about moving forward, you know?
So what, where exactly is this
and what was their war? You're,
you've heard of Chechnya. Yeah. Yeah. So
they had a war with Russia, I civil war.
So see that's what it used to look like.
Yeah. Now you've got a picture of it now,
right? Yeah. So it's there.
Ah, there it is now rebuilding.
Yeah. And there that rebuilt
their, their energetic about it,
and there's prior to then,
and it's cool as a coach to be
able to go there and get to see it.
That is cool to see something in the
middle of a rebirth like that. Right.
It's beautiful. And in that
area, a lot of places. Yeah,
there's a lot of rebirth energy going on.
Oh Wow.
So that's what it looked like
right after the war. God Damn. Wow.
That's a crazy image.